now the Senators confirmed Steven minus
China's Treasury secretary ending one of
the tougher confirmation battles for
president Trump's cabinet pigs let's get
more and joining us is now ray me in a
sense ear here Amy yeah well finally the
US has its lead man on economic policy
as well as on those promised tax cuts
from President Donald Trump as well as
the potential declawing or deregulation
out of dodd-frank here now the vote came
in just less than an hour ago rich and
it was almost along party lines 53 247
the if it were along a party line vote
that woulda been 52 to 48 one Democrat
crossing the aisle to support manoush in
here but this had been fraught with
boycotts especially from the Democrats
boycotting the Senate Finance Committee
hearing last week to try to derail his
nomination and it turns out
interestingly that it's been three weeks
rich ever since the US actually had
another working Treasury secretary and
according to lawmakers that's the
longest amount of time ever that there
has been a leadership vacuum at the top
of the Treasury Secretary a position but
looking ahead in terms of what he is
going to be dealing with along with
those cuts to taxes that have been
promised by mr. Trump and deregulation
most importantly March 15 look at that
the expiration of the u.s. debt ceiling
suspension many people are hoping that
he will help the u.s. avoid a default on
u.s. debt and just a few days later
March 17 to March 18 he should be going
to Germany because there's going to be a
g20 finance ministers meeting as well as
a Board of Governors meeting there so he
is definitely heading into this position
now confirmed with a very full plate in
just the next few weeks ratio well we've
got also the new president meeting with
the Canadian Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau any idea what was on the agenda
that what topics did they discuss it
perhaps maybe more important is what
they have didn't you know they talked
about the the main topics that you would
expect them to talk about they talked
about economic policy they talked about
trade and they talked about security
that's going to take a listen
specifically actually we don't have
enough
so we won't go there but basically they
said that the their economic ties are
strong and that they're going to
continue to be here and especially
because 35 US states interestingly here
list Canada is our largest export market
dealing with two billion dollars each
day in bilateral trade rich